hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
no I'm John Humphrey who you gonna watch
the video for Marco kind talks about
Christian Bale's run Oh John I've been
quoting that rant on her own time for
like ten years
speaking of ten years this is coming
from Cameron French topper war to your
request for patreon it is the ten year
anniversary of my favorite Terminator
film but Terminator Salvation yes the
best John Connor interpretation you
killed my mother
mmm Ferguson he was great and before he
got taken over by that British guy I
know it's carpals he is hilarious Corden
[Applause]
they release the tapes of heaven beetle
angry on a film set yeah pay this guy to
be unstable and crazy right that was a
big special effects picture right right
it takes ages to come out they recorded
this during shooting and record never
came on the television and the radio
till the week it was being released
isn't that suspicious
[Music]
[Music]
why Craig is a great host and michael
caine's a great guest i don't know how
well this interview would have gone over
today people being like you're just
normalizing treating people
disrespectful onset is an okay thing you
know like everything like what he would
say I'm like that Jeffrey Tambor thing
wasn't put down lightly when they
arrested development gasps did that
interview of Jason Bateman Nance blamed
the whole situation freakin Jason
Bateman personality everybody came out
and apologized in tandem yeah and then
Arrested Development didn't promote or
anything that's always the funny thing
to me about actors in general what Craig
Ferguson brought up I haven't heard this
before but that is almost word-for-word
what I've said about what I found
fascinating about Christian Bale is that
he can play a rageful Batman he can play
an American Psycho and we go brilliant
beautiful the day he has a slip-up they
catch him in this moment in time where
he's gone crazy on set one day then
suddenly it's like and I know there's a
line between professional is like you
can't treat people like yet I got that
thousand percent a bad agree I'm saying
I find it fascinating how people we
praise them for a performance and that's
part of why I think acting is a cool and
beautiful thing because you can be
Rachel and you get praised for that or
you know real life a lot of times that
people cry people say stop crying stop
crying about on camera you're like good
tears you know I'm off yet when you do
knee have that moment which he'd like
apologize for Andy actually I'm
remembering that knee you say someone
came to your school and talked about
that they were on set that day oh man
you said like the an ad or something
came by and they talked about how
everyone you remember you told me that
how ad came by on set and said oh they
made up like soon after like like yeah
they said they yeah they talked and they
kind of rectified the situation not long
after that happened and things kind of
returned to normal I remember John's
story I was trying to set him up o to
tell the story that he told me 10 years
ago and he can't remember remember yeah
we're talking about this part of the
story usually it's just quotes from the
tape I thought I thought I like this in
the background what the [ __ ] yeah I know
it is the best tape ever and the remix
it is so far it's funny how funny that
context is like oh my god he's going
crazy huh but after a while you're like
this [ __ ] is so funny because he's so
over-the-top ridiculously mad in it and
it's so unreasonable no way you're in do
I want no no don't shut me up and you
just laugh at like oh like big G
pussying out I think it's funny because
we've all dealt with idiots before who
we want her to lose her [ __ ] so there's
a weird thing where you're judging
Christian Bale for how ridiculous he is
at the same time I think we all have to
relate about yeah we have to admit
ourselves there's something about how
angry is that it's also a relatable yeah
yeah my story yeah well you said the
Navy came to your school and he said
that the set was just all already so
tense and the weather conditions they
were dealing with yeah hard yeah that
someone was bad said someone was gonna
lose it
and it just happened to be yeah first
yeah yeah yeah I remembered that part
it's alright thank you for jogging my
memory but yeah no I I have heard it and
and from others you know people I'm sure
it's out there online too that that was
a difficult set I don't know I mean you
shouldn't act that way you shouldn't be
abusive like that but at the same time I
think none of us were there in that
particular situation so you had to it's
not belaboring the point calm down and
yeah maybe no just here until I can
anger blame game of course they don't
have the apology on camera
well but but even that guy came I was
like yeah we made up yeah yeah yeah one
the the thing too is I think the problem
for Christian Bale comes in more with
the fact that the the conflicts he's had
with his what is its wife and sister or
whatever there there was like some kind
of situation involving his family I
think he killed them yeah he played
around with their boys but no I think
he's had some kind of domestic disputes
in the past that are a bit muddy like
not so cleanly cut that we've canceled
him or whatever but at least enough to
be like oh maybe this guy has more than
just an isolated incidents worth of an
anger problem I thought it was cool if
Michael came to to basically own up and
be like hey man I had a temper back in
the day and I did worse than this we're
this progressive stage where we're
trying to like cut that [ __ ] out
permanently you know like that just
really say it's not okay I've heard more
of more than actors being like crazy
I've heard more like directors going
crazy have you seen the footage of damn
what's that directors name David
O'Russell yeah the set of I Heart
Huckabees
is it was crazy who was a great friend
of Christian pickles and they worked
together several times I don't know I
mean I appreciate Christian Bale's
talent and he amuses me as a person from
time to time but I I mean if they both
have a temper issue I could see how
birds of a feather and all that stuff I
think this is interesting too because
you know Craig Ferguson just you know
has such a history and has lived
so much life and has you know been
through a lot of you know he knows the
industry and he has so many personal
life things I actually know you have a
pretty big attachment of him you've seen
even went to one of the tapings right
couple yeah yeah but he's also like had
to basically reform his life from a lot
of bad behavior to over time and that's
why I think he can be an understanding I
remember like he talked about Mel Gibson
once we know what his problem is he's an
alcoholic
he's got alcoholism and then what he's
in tune with alcohol this behavior comes
out yeah I always appreciated his
ability to come out at this top a
certain shows and be very just direct
and you know not do jokes sometimes when
there was something important to say you
know yeah I feel like it's always
important to have jokes that always
there always a few to break the tension
well Cameron French thanks for
requesting this buddy guys in
celebration of Terminator Salvation go
watch it today what's sad is when I
heard that rant I was like he's probably
gonna give a damn good before that is
easily like the one Christian Bale
performance I do not like I love or like
all his performances and that is the
only one I've seen I'm like no I
remember I shot
Cameron French a while ago and I was
joking about how we talked so much yet I
know jack about this guy he gave me some
information here and I want to share
with you guys he's from Florida I didn't
know that I asked if I could send him a
thank-you letter he refused they said he
saw Kevin Smith at an auction with San
Lee year before he died I met Val Kilmer
30 minutes this is me talking he met Val
Kilmer 30 minutes after he had emergency
surgery on his throat due to his throat
cancer and signed his Batman mask he got
AIDS I want to use that story and he's
undercover with the Bureau of paranormal
research that is a reference to 20 19th
biggest box office hit yeah he'll
Helmand damn good one Helmand oh that's
been hell boys should have like multiple
children yeah
boys yeah cross it over the bad boys got
yourself one hell of a time damn